good afternoon my name is Jim Levinson
I'm the director of the Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs here at
Yale the Jackson Institute is the home
of the newly established Johnson center
for the study of American diplomacy and
one of the neat things that that Center
brings to us is a Kissinger senior
fellow very accomplished senior diplomat
who comes in spends time here at Yale to
teach this year the inaugural Kissinger
senior fellow is ambassador Ryan Crocker
Ryan is former ambassador to Afghanistan
Iraq Pakistan Syria Kuwait and Lebanon
he's a recipient of the presidential
medal of freedom I've had just a little
bit of time to get to know ambassador
Crocker he arrived oh just about a week
ago but in the interim he's had at least
a trip to Istanbul a trip to the west
coast he's been meeting a number of
other commitments and in my head my idea
of what an ambassador actually does was
initially came from watching the movies
and and I thought well ambassadors they
they have these palatial residences and
they they oversee really really nice
parties and engage in witty repartee and
that was before I took the job that I
have now and then about a year ago I had
the privilege of spending a little bit
of time at one of the u.s. ambassadors
residences in Europe and you know it was
elegant it was it really was right out
of central casting it was about 80,000
square feet and sure enough we had
classical music playing in the
background and people engaged in witty
repartee I then on Friday I picked up
Envestnet ambassador Ryan and I was
casually asking you know so where were
you living and he was describing a
trailer that he shared with six people
in a very very hot I think that might
have been in Iraq and I asked about
music and I was hoping I'd at least get
some of it right and I said what kind of
music do you listen to and he said well
I like five finger death punch right it
didn't sound like classical music but in
the in the
in the spirit of doing research for my
job over the weekend I actually got
online and I downloaded some of their
music sir it's awful when we an
ambassador Crocker before some travel
commitments got in the way said he was
thinking of driving his pickup truck out
from the west coast I realized I wasn't
dealing with the person i imagined out
of central casting it is a tremendous
privilege to have you here ambassador
Crocker is teaching while he's here at
Yale in fact next class is in this in
this very room at one o'clock and then
tomorrow and two more seminars coming up
in the winter term the way we'll do
things today is ambassador Crocker will
speak for I don't know something maybe
like 20 30 minutes and then we'll do
question and answer there's a debate
tonight there's a lot of stuff going on
in the part of the world where he has
tremendous expertise and we'll try to
get a conversation going Thank You
ambassador Crocker
well you know the one of things I tell
you is never get in an argument with
your boss particularly early in your
tenure but I just got to tell you you're
dead wrong on 500 death punch on me so
as presser Levinson noted I've been here
about nine days now split pretty much
evenly between Turkey and the west coast
I can find my way home with assistance
here in Yale what I was doing most
recently in Turkey from which I returned
just last night was attending a a
conference on Syria whatever are we
going to do about Syria as that
revolution Civil War massive
bloodletting not only continues but the
demons I'd like to start by just making
a few observations if I could Syria is
obviously part of if you will the
broader Arab Spring and what I would
give you is an organizational context to
to to frame our discussion is first
almost two years into this this is just
the beginning of this transformational
process it is Act one Scene one second
it is the most profound political change
within the Middle East since the
revolutions of the 1950s that affect not
only the region but that reaches far
beyond to to our to our own interest
third in a very interesting sense it's
the the mirror image of the revolutions
of the 1950s because those revolutions
either threatened or toppled traditional
regimes monarchies in in in different
parts of the Arab world in Iraq in Egypt
in the Sudan in Libya now what we're
seeing is a really remarkable stability
on the part of the monarchies that
survived the 58 the risings of the 50s
while it's the Republic's born in that
era without exception that are suffering
the process of regime change because
it's the Middle East there are no hard
and fast rules you know bahrain as a
monarchy did go through a challenge
because of its sectarian balance a Sunni
majority Sunni minority ruling a Shia
majority who really don't like that but
it wrote it out it's been quiet and
bought right now for for many months and
in Algeria one of the Republic's
remarkably quiet I have this map up here
not because you don't know the geography
of the Middle East intimately
even if you did you couldn't find
Bahrain that's the name but the island
is too small to show it already went
through its Arab Spring if you will in
the the brutal resistance to French
occupation or brutal resistance to a
brutal occupation in the war for
independence and then to a marked
extensa the product of that fight at the
end of the Afghan war the first Afghan
heck the fifth Afghan war fifth Afghan
war in the night since the 19th century
those returning jihadis after the
Soviets were defeated then produced in
Islamic rebellion that resulted in the
loss of thousands of lives and the
attitude in Algeria to the Arab Spring
has been there done that not going back
now I mentioned that I'm just back from
Istanbul this is was a track to event in
which you gathered together a lot of
former officials and allow them to say
whatever they want to say it's really
kind of fun because none of us are
beholding to governments anymore well
the Iranian is kind of but it was quite
a gathering we had representatives it
was it was small about 20 of us but
representatives from Iran Turkey Lebanon
Jordan Iraq the Gulf states a jip a
Kurdish representative and a Palestinian
internationally the United States the
United Kingdom China Russia the European
Union there there was actually consensus
on a few points first hold presses this
will be a shock there is a leadership
vacuum within the syria syrian
opposition no clear a single individual
group or collection of groups has yet
emerged secondly the situation is likely
to worsen and as it worsens it is likely
to drive both sides to ever greater
extremes something we're already seeing
both with the regime and with the
resistance and third as it moves toward
extremes particularly among the
opposition the
idiom for that opposition is
increasingly Islamic militant to
militancy again Syria has a long history
that has fed this tendency that be happy
to discuss in in in QA and finally there
was broad consensus on waiting for the
United States to do something this was
divided in two camps those who want the
United States to do something active and
dramatic to change the dynamic and those
who are afraid that that's exactly what
we will do and that is where consensus
breaks down you may have noted that
unlike Libya no security council
resolution on Syria has emerged that is
because there are fundamental
disagreements among the p5 permanent
five members of the council as to what a
resolution should say China has
exercised and it's its veto right and
unprecedented three times in six months
it has never done that before but it
absolutely will not tolerate nor will
Russia a resolution that calls for
regime change in syria among these three
there are points of similarity there
must be a negotiated settlement
international legitimacy must be
respected in other words no regime
change by force the fall of Bashar
al-assad is most likely to be a disaster
for the region not a boon to it we are
locked in a bloody stalemate neither
side can win so there must be a
political solution the problem with all
of that which you know sounds great on
paper is that both sides the opposition
and the regime have made it clear not
interested don't want a political
solution don't even want to talk about
having talks the regime has been
extraordinarily clear on this point
it'll start talking when the rebellion
is a style it has been put down by force
and all is the silence of a graveyard
the opposition less United has a similar
view let me I should note something else
everything is connected to everything
else in this difficult region and I
heard from the Chinese something
interesting you know it's not just about
oil and stability the to be linked in
Chinese foreign policy imperatives it's
also about fears and suspicions of what
the u.s. may be up to much more broadly
the Chinese representative spoke of
concerns even fears in beijing / what
exactly we intend through our so called
rebalancing in which we are
intending to shift focus to East Asia is
this something fairly benign and may be
economically motivated it or is it a
direct threat to the Chinese nation and
he was quite blunt that as they look at
Syria they do also through that prism
particularly the question of regime
change one more regime change led by the
US and you know those who might be next
let me quickly run you through the views
of the participants because even with
considerable experience in this region I
found some of them things I didn't
expect the United States I think you
know ambassador forward restated our
position I believe on Friday we believe
that Bashar al Assad must go there can
be no solution with him in power we are
stepping up our non-lethal aid to the
Syrian opposition we are intensifying
our outreach to the opposition and I'll
come back to this because it's important
and we're doing so both to better
understand them and frankly to influence
them we have also sent troops for
exercises to to Jordan and to Israel
lest any mischief makers in the region
get some bold ideas and the Europeans
you know it would be funny if it wasn't
so sad they were quite frank both the
German and the EU representative that
they haven't got a plan and don't be
looking in that direction for one
anytime soon the German said Germany of
course worships sanctions problem is
sanctions won't work and it particularly
won't work in this type of situation for
reasons we can we can cover and they
believe that Assad must go but not
necessarily the whole regime something I
think we would share and I'll come back
to that at the conclusion and the EU rep
who is a old friend of mine has been
with the European Union for years and
years and years including in Syria where
we served together said what's they said
EU policy is hopelessly fragmented on
this question again a microcosm if you
will of international dissension and
fragmentation and the Gulf states were
the most aggressive and forward leaning
the west and the region have to step up
it's time to send in weapons the regime
as military support superiority people
are getting slaughtered the west and the
US with its dithering is responsible for
the deaths of thousands of innocent
civilians pretty strong words Iran and
Hezbollah are operating under no such
constraints but we the West the u.s. in
particular are holding back the right
thinkers in the region who would like to
come to the material aid of the Syrian
opposition
Qatar and Saudi Arabia are in the lead
on this but the Gulf representatives
argued that there is broad consensus
that this is the right way to to proceed
GCC acknowledged in Istanbul that the
Gulf had been surprised by the Arab
Spring didn't see it coming and
initially felt that they were losing
some good friends and allies especially
Hosni Mubarak in Egypt but they then
stepped up the challenge of facing the
inevitable and working to support a new
order they tried and is this true King
Abdullah of Saudi Arabia has long had
close relations to the Assad regime
father and son he made three efforts
with Bashar al-assad to get him to agree
to a negotiated settlement or at least
negotiations toward settlement and was
rebuffed each time the Gulf
representatives were also remarkably
frank in saying what in terms this is
this is a sectarian conflict they are
under great pressure from their
populations to take action in support of
the Syrian rebels against the regime and
as you all know this is the rebels of
course are overwhelmingly Sunni Muslims
while the regime is Allah we led the
alois being a schism of Shia Islam so as
he said this is an opportunity for the
Gulf states to hand the defeat in the
region to the non Sunnis to the Syrian
regime
Allawi to Hezbollah in Lebanon she and
of course to Iran itself it's just the
US and standing in its way and i'll come
back to this in a minute to as as we
look at some of the longer term
ramifications of of the Arab Spring the
Turks were also interested I had
expected much more negativity from them
reflecting their earlier positions and
indeed the Turk said they had expected
more from the US leadership after
President Obama's initial statements
they thought we were really going to
gear up for this that in their view did
not happen now as a result they have
become more cautious a hawkish foreign
minister of Turkey amida buddha lu who
read the obama statements and made a few
of his own very very harsh very sharp on
the need for military intervention in
syria has been sharply criticized by
turkish public opinion three-quarters of
which at least according to the Turks
want absolutely nothing whatsoever to do
with any kind of turkish LED or turkish
unilateral intervention on the positive
side the turks after some initial alarm
are less concerned they feel that
they're much improved relations with the
Kurds of northern Iraq have given them
kind of a buffer here and indeed Kurdish
representatives not of their heads to
this because of the other profitable
nature of Kurdish Turkish relations
right now
what could be a disturbing from a turkey
standpoint moved toward Turkish or
creation dependence very much under
control at the present time because both
sides are making some real big bucks on
things like oil and and finally again
here is something I had not thought of
and didn't expect the Turk said yeah
we're little annoyed with the Americans
but you know what at a strategic level
this whole thing was Syria has actually
brought turkey and the West closer turks
in a way they have not for some number
of years now appreciate in value
importance of the Western alliance of
which their part if things really come
unglued in their neighborhood they like
the idea of being part of NATO so again
hey this is the broader Middle East
don't expect consistency it's a why we
talked to people with different
viewpoints the most fearful of all
probably the Lebanese and our conference
was punctuated by the assassination of
wissam al-hassan while we were in
Istanbul a senior Lebanese internal
security forces wealthy senior
intelligence chief who played a very
important role in the investigation
among other things of assassination of
former prime minister rafik hariri and
who has been a vocal critic of the
syrians not a lot of time spent
speculating on who might be behind it
there is
fear therefore that once again Lebanon
will be the victim that the Civil War
will return stoked by various factions
in Syria and outside there is fear that
whoever wins whether it's the Assad
regime or some collation of
oppositionists Lebanon's going to lose
and they may be exactly right about that
this was a subtext that came through a
number of the presentations don't count
the regime in Damascus out by any means
they have prepared for this moment for
decades they are organized for it they
know what the consequences are if they
lose death so they're not going to lose
they have the weapons they have the
germination they have the organization
so again are some of our Western
pundants to say it's all over not so
sure people who live closest to it don't
think so and indeed to the wissam
al-hassan assassination we've seen they
can punch right back and are likely to
continue to to do so the Iranians are
afraid they're also going to be a
strategic loser here and we're quite
clear on Syria the Syrian regime as a
non sunni-shia faction has been their
only friend in the Arab world they they
don't want to lose it as the Iranian
representative put it it was Syria and
only Syria among the Arabs
who stood by them during the horrific
iran-iraq war of 82 288 they are
especially worried about another
government in the region with a Shia
ascendancy right now which is Iraq they
see the opposition has doing what it did
when I first got to Iraq in 2007 which
is reopening a pipeline of foreign
fighters predominantly al Qaeda into
Iraq where they are wreaking murder and
mayhem and the Iranian was disinclined
to address Hizbollah he never used the
word even though we questioned him on it
I didn't really want to talk about
Lebanon an affair for the Lebanese
comment that no one's face could be kept
straight on but he I think was genuinely
concerned about their their western
flank with with Syria with the with Iraq
and he again made the point nothing good
will come from the fall of the regime
not for any of us incidentally on Iraq
as he worried about the prospects of
Civil War I was sitting next to him just
to make him uncomfortable he had turned
to me and he said you know part of this
is your fault and yeah I was expecting
that from the Iranians but the reason
was was fairly extraordinary he said
your your premature withdrawal from Iraq
removed a stabilizing factor at the
worst possible moment
you know if you are still there in force
we would be a lot less worried in Tehran
and we are now an interesting point
these were chatham house rules which is
why I'm not mentioning any names but i
doubt if those remarks were cleared in
in tehran the egyptian representative of
the new dispensation in Egypt again gave
a particularly Egyptian perspective he
said you know for four decades Syria has
has stood as a symbol of Arab
nationalism a verra bonner air a virtue
of confrontation with the west and the
u.s. to preserve that honor and those
virtues so as the regime gives up its
legitimacy in that area how can I pose
as a defender of air of the Arab
nationalism and Arab honor when they are
busy slaughtering the population that
happens to be what the majority of other
Arabs are Sunni Muslims so they whatever
happens according to Egyptian they have
thoroughly discredited themselves for
what had been for so many years the most
important hallmark of their policy
support for Arab nationalism so for
Egypt while they're concerned about the
growing jihadi influence they unbalanced
depending on how this plays to see the
regime's problems in Damascus as overall
a net positive from Egyptian strategic
perspectives
first Iran gets isolated my Iranian and
colleague wasted that but didn't deny it
but second with Syria and Egypt in
competition ever since the 50s and the
Gamal Abdel Nasser coup for the
leadership role in the Arab world now
see a chance that they never had before
to assume that role in spite of their
current challenges and problems at least
they're nothing like what Syria is
facing Jordan you know don't worry be
happy there was no impact to the Arab
Spring Syria or otherwise and Jordan and
they have just returned their ambassador
to Israel meaning they're not worried
about any kind of backlash from that
quarter and the post-war order is highly
durable and will resist all of this
they've been through worse etc etc that
of course was just before yesterday's
announcement that Jordanian intelligence
had done covered a very significant
al-qaeda plot to attack a range of
targets inside the kingdom he did say
something else everyone had something
that he didn't expect he thought that
out of all of this debacle might arise a
new push for Jordanian Palestinian unity
that has been at best elusive
if not wholly fictional since the
creation of the jordanian state but
better to hang together then run the
risk of hanging separately so at least
again you know another thought another
thing to watch as we move forward so so
now what couple more observations I mean
al Qaeda is a continuing to gain ground
both in Syria and as the Arab Spring
unfolds as the government's opposed to
al Qaeda in the past like like Egypt
even Libya Syria to some degree now have
their hands full with just just trying
to stay alive hard if not impossible to
bring the resources to impose order and
again you know we've seen them in Yemen
we have seen them in Iraq we certainly
see them in Syria the Egyptians are very
worried about what may come next I manos
lottery the current head of the Qaeda
headquarters in the afghan-pakistan
border area is an Egyptian and of course
the manifold woes of both Pakistan and
Afghanistan are likely to worsen as al
Qaeda gains momentum what we may see as
well though are some interesting new
alignments
again the monarchy's have not suffered
the their Republican in many cases
adversaries have and you could clearly
see it from a very assertive a pair of
GCC representatives you know this is
their chance to finally assert the kind
of leadership that they've been unable
to do so before because of regional
powers like Egypt in Syria what will
that mean how will that play out how
will the non monarca chol states react
and again I apologize for not defining
my terms up front to the GCC Gulf
Cooperation Council saudi arabia oman
the UAE Qatar Bahrain and Kuwait in
addition to other capabilities they are
home to a huge percentage of world's oil
and with major actors sidelined we may
see a far more assertive role by the GCC
they're probably going to need someone
other than a 90 year old King Abdullah
of Saudi Arabia to do that but watch
that watch that space farther afield at
least in probability if not
geographically let's remind range over
the possibilities the moderate tone of
the Iranian representative made me think
that there might be something going on
in Tehran yeah they have to stick with
Bashar sorta sort of kinda but if the
horse is going to lose
you don't want to be the last one
betting on it so you may see an effort
to put together a closer iran-iraq
relationship his emphasis on Iraq and
concerns over Iraq put that in my mind
if Syria goes could Iraq be the new
Syria for Iran deeply troubling to us
but in order for that to happen there's
a lot of baggage that is going to have
to be shoved over the side Iraq is not
going to tolerate an Iran that supports
his bullet the way it has in the past
because in the not too distant past when
I was in Iraq they were also supporting
a Hezbollah like militia element called
jaysh almighty the army of the mighty
trained in fact in many cases by
Hezbollah and used against not only us
but also Iraqi security forces that in
turn reawakened all the old Iraqi
nightmares of the 8288 iran-iraq war
lost to the memories of history in this
country and the rest of the West the day
before yesterday just like World War
want is for the Europeans okay so what
to do here are some random thoughts some
of which are already in motion some of
which I think need to be placed in
motion one that is already in motion as
I noted at the outset is figure out who
are those guys in the Syrian opposition
they are divided they are fragmented
they are not household works again the
nature of the Assad regime made sure
that no leadership emerged during times
of stability because you get your head
handed to you that is not a figurative
term in Syria so let's figure it out
let's do it as a collective effort both
regionally and internationally you know
we're all smarter collectively than any
of us are individually and as we figure
it out let's share those assessments and
be sure we're not just trying to
understand who they are we're working to
influencing assistance is a great thing
but my own view is it needs to be
conditional you will get this if you do
that and we're saying that to you
because we got to know where you stand
who's behind you what you're going to do
under a variety of circumstances we got
to test this so that'd be one basket of
issues the second is the mirror opposite
I think we need to do a great deal more
as I implied earlier to understand the
Alawis regime highly secretive very
difficult even in times of relative
tranquility to know who the players are
on how decisions are made probably even
harder now they really close in on
themselves but it's important that we
collectively make that assessment who
are they vice president paducah Shara
not a nollie we just got thrown over the
side well why did that happen you know
are we circling wagons here is their
perception of an internal threat what's
going on why is this important because
we might be able to do what we did in
Iraq against the al-qaeda led Sunni
opposition when I was there
not all not all alleyways are of the
same view and I think an intelligent
quiet initiative that is aimed at first
understanding who they are and then
figuring out who might be vulnerable to
blandishments threats intimidation
whatever it's a rough game but how might
the hitherto relatively monolithic
Beshara regime be weakened people said
we couldn't do it in Iraq what we did I
don't think it has been seriously
attempted even to the analytical point
in Syria but particularly if our
non-american friends are right that that
regime is a far cry from collapse then
we really need to go to town and figure
out how to move them farther down that
spectrum a third point you know forget
the United Nations it's not the United
Nations fault the Security Council
simply cannot work we are wasting our
time and we are looking and effective
this calls for a Coalition of the
Willing and and there is a lot of will
out there if there is some leadership
that would be us and we want to make it
as broad as possible and you know who
knows if momentum builds it is not
inconceivable that the Chinese and the
Russians could shift their views but you
can't beat something with nothing and
what I think we have to demonstrate is a
serious effort to create a Coalition of
the Willing that can be a game changing
dynamic in a number of areas both inside
Syria in the region and
national community as they see that well
maybe we are not just simply dithering
while Syria burns to other ideas that
occur to me again I apologize I'm
seriously jet-lagged and sleep-deprived
so if some of them sound a bit
far-fetched well I aim to stimulate
thinking first would be an Arab
initiative well you know Gulf
Cooperation Council is talking a great
game they're ready to go to war this is
what we're holding back what if we said
okay now you'll need to work your own
deal with the Turks will help but that
modern air forces that we provided for
you so why not put a couple of squadrons
of Gulf aircraft up in Turkey you know
show the world you're serious we'll see
how serious they are I like the idea the
other was a thought triggered by my
colleague from Turkey saying it in a
converse if not perverse way this whole
crisis has actually brought turkey
closer to the NATO alliance and it has
been for many years well maybe somebody
should have a quiet discussion with the
Turks about them invoking chapter 5 of
the NATO declaration collective
self-defense provides we used it
provides that any country that feels
threatened may under Chapter five call
for the assistance of all of NATO and
NATO is contractually obliged through a
treaty legally binding to respond I
think we're a long way from that and I
think we're farther away from it having
heard the Turks
but boy oh boy would that be a game
changer you know as all of NATO would
look at each other and said a little God
it's a led by us but that's another
matter the final thought I have is
unless any of this is sounded overly
optimistic I you know I'm no scholar as
I'm going to be proving endlessly
day-to-day week-to-week months and
months here at Yale but all of us an
important service do full of some
academic pursuit you cannot make sense
of the world as a practitioner of
diplomacy if you don't have some frame
of reference in order to do so many of
my colleagues follow political science I
tend to favor history found that that is
more helpful to me in understanding the
Middle East which is obsessed with its
history at least its own version of it
and as I look at the troubled levante
the labott being composed of syria
lebanon jordan and palestine which I
units in its old historical Samuel a
shin I was a political statement of all
of the regions of the Middle East that
have had their trials and tribulations
with the West arguably the Levant is the
least stable and the most fractious the
four states of the Levant or four and a
half counting the Palestinian
territories you know unlike the rest of
the region did not come into legal being
until after World War two it is highly
instructive since everybody's got a lot
of spare time to read Philip Hetty's
history of the herbs
it was written in 1937 it is one of the
best lo these many years later
treatments of Arab history Filippetti as
an Anglo Lebanese now knew where of he
spoke because he swam in those waters
doesn't talk about Lebanon or Palestine
certainly not Israel or Jordan he talks
about Syria because at that time when I
thought that long ago in historical
terms this was all greater Syria and for
many Syrians it still should be so my
final caution on this says this moves
forward watch out that we don't see
strength coming out of weakness an
effort by the regime by the opponents of
the regime or some devilish combination
of both to work to destabilize Jordan
Lebanon the Palestinians they would be
extremely wise to give Israel a pass
right now but what you may be seen it
particularly some of the events in
Lebanon always the weakest read could be
an effort to reassert in this new Arab
Spring that is still very much a warning
the old greater Syria so having
sufficiently charged you for a monday
afternoon i'd be happy to take your
observations and questions
having left almost no time for said
questions happy too happy to be around
as long as you're interested in a word I
don't think it threatens us diplomacy it
was a big splash at the time but it was
amazing to me or interesting at least
you know after the initial furor died
down how little I heard from foreign
interlocutors about WikiLeaks or you
said that about me you lying sob I don't
recall a single Afghan during my time
there ever raising WikiLeaks didn't come
up with this conference I think part of
the reason is for those who practice the
dark arts no real surprises there that's
what diplomats do hey you know we have
conversations we report those
conversations and we make assessments
about the converse e depending on the
nature of the assessment the party of
the second part may not find it too holy
to his or her liking but it's not a no
mega surprise yet it has changed in a
way I gotta tell you not prescient in
any manner well before WikiLeaks back
when I was in Pakistan which was before
most of you were born as ambassador
highly sensitive issues and in Iraq also
some highly sensitive issues well
neither the WikiLeaks of the present or
the historians of the future
ever going to find the cables I wrote on
those highly sensitive issues because I
didn't write any the best way to ensure
that a cable doesn't get leaked is not
to write it so you know my sensitive
work was always done by secure video or
secure telephone with a very very
limited number of people and I got to
tell you there with one exception I did
send a cable through highly secure
channels in Afghanistan it was leaked
and guess what i sent it with the
expectation that it wouldn't because it
it furthered my agenda so I like them I
diplomacy spine thanks for the talk
investor pockets language is about the
changing role of multilateralism and I
think in my attention multilaterally
some of it is that all of the world's
apart of it
of it but it seems like recently some of
that has begun to erode whether it's
through it Syria completely blocking
access to the commission of inquiry or
Israel cutting ties with the Human
Rights Council things things like that
that seemed that that seemed to cut away
at the legitimacy me that that comes
about as a result of multi multilateral
organizations representing all states
and in in tandem with what some of what
you said about you know the United
Nations is failing to address the
situation I was wondering how you see
this as it can to much to go on
especially adds there are concurrent
discussions happening all the time about
Security Council reform about about
about things like that and how or if the
United Nations can actually continue to
adapt well the United Nations has been
remarkably resilient you know given its
deep structural flaws and can only blame
ourselves I mean we were the principal
architect in San Francisco the creation
of the United Nations it suffers both
from political and institutional
weaknesses you know politically the need
for consensus well you know t5 the
vetoes that can be very hard to come by
and I think what we're really looking at
here is a you know a failure of the UN
not through the to the fall of its
members not the organization to deal in
any meaningful way with Syria and I
don't see that changing at least until
some other coalition might galvanize a
rethink on the part of the recalcitrant
Security Council members the other
weakness of the United Nations is
structural and I got to tell you I mean
it
it drives me nuts I'm an operator you
know I've always seen my job to you know
make good things happen and prevent bad
things from happening and do it in
arenas where you better be quick on your
feet lest events overtake you the United
Nations is not equipped to do this in
particular the specialized agencies many
of whom play very important roles have a
frightening level of Independence from
healing headquarters the specialized
agencies can pretty much do what they
want they don't need permission they
don't even need consultation so it means
if you know you're a Western diplomat
trying to get a UN position on a
particular issue not only you have to
worry about the politics of it you've
got to talk to half a dozen different
agencies and sign them all up for it oh
and by the way many of those agencies
hate each other you know bureaucratic
rivalries driven by a resource
competition so we talk about you and
reform we've been talking about forever
you know whatever we do I hope we don't
expand a Security Council it's bad
enough with five make it a dozen and
you're guaranteed permanent deadlock all
of that said I am a big proponent
proponent of multilateralism I just
think we've got to be creative and we
need to think about going beyond
existing structures that's why I talked
about a Coalition of the Willing lets
you know put up your hand if you're
ready to sit down and do some of the
things on that menu I laid out I better
under a rock two tours I never want to
see us do that again it came out a lot
better than it should have but I don't
think we did ourselves were the
International order
that much good but we do have to be
clear-eyed about the realities and
limitations of some of the systems and
the way certain countries including our
own from time to time will you know use
those systems to further national agenda
rather than a greater good so you know
it's a combination and took in a deep
breaths and you know understanding what
the limits of the possible are but also
of looking for other creative
alternatives that I don't think really
undercut any of the existing
international institutions they can add
to it if a Coalition of the Willing for
example gained some traction causes
China and Russia to reevaluate what the
position is that strengthened see you
and rather than the contrary one we kick
one take one more question presentation
my question is this you said it
correctly this is sectarian war
minority of how to do the always there
is a small minority that is afraid of
the Missouri the Sunni majority in that
area if the Sunni leaders in say Saudi
Arabia and the Gulf states and other
parts of the Sunni world or to come out
and say to the halloween minorities in
Syria hey don't worry we will make sure
that you are not harmed if there's a
regime change we will make sure that
your home's your villages are not
attacked if there is a regime change do
you think that that would make a
difference in the conflict thank you
it's a great question I think initially
the emphasis here needs to be part of a
discussion with the Syrian opposition I
mean here are the ones they were there
for for them to individually and
collectively say just what you said and
maybe you make it a little easier for
them to start to start with the the non
Halloween minorities now Drew's
Christians and then push toward what you
suggest that is also in my view part of
the strategy of dividing and conquering
you know some of the hour.we
establishment it doesn't matter what you
put on the table but for others they may
very well say you know this ain't worth
dying for I believe these you know I
believe these commitments so what's
let's let's let's see where it goes now
all of that said I got to tell you I did
not come away with a warm fuzzy feeling
in terms of attitudes in particularly
the Gulf Cooperation Council States
there was nothing about all the branches
there was nothing about bringing alois
into the discussion it was all about
this is our chance
to assert suniye nomination so you know
it is possible that given the realities
of the region it is likely to be a
pretty heavy lift and as I said earlier
the dynamics of Syrian internal politics
going back at least to the 1982 massacre
in the city of Hama of up to 20,000
Syrian cities as Assad sought to
eliminate the Muslim brothers he did you
know a couple hundred of them you know
the other 1000 or 1800 18,800 had
nothing to do with that fight the Sunnis
have never forgotten it and it is going
to make that kind of compromise pretty
hard to achieve if the opposition looks
like it's going to dominate and of
course the alois use that to play on
fears of their community other thing I'd
say about assurances because I just I
feel like I've been to relentlessly
upbeat hear it you've probably heard of
the Sabra shatila massacres September
1982 among other checkered moments in my
past I was the American diplomat who
entered those camps and discovered that
massacre and reported it to Washington
we don't know how many died men women
children certainly hundreds maybe well
in excess of that they were killed in
the face of written assurances from the
government of the United States that
Palestinian civilians who reign remain
behind as the PLO evacuated Beirut at
the end of August 1982
would have their safety guaranteed a
pretty hollow statement as I went
through that camp counting those bodies
now alois haven't forgotten that nobody
in the Middle East is forgotten so if we
broke or some assurances saying olly
olly income free it's all going to be
okay trust us yeah you and what army so
again history history history